[Applaudissements]
elles vont se présenter toutes les trois
on va accueillir la première d'entre
elles attention c'est parti
musique
[Applaudissements]
je suis logique et oui l'année
je n'y ai jamais
ap
[Musique]
m
mais les matinales de galles
[Musique]
moi
bien sûr c'est bon c'est déjà beau chat
de la saison michel jean michel baylet
ouais c'est vrai que là on a un micro
pour 6 à 12
jean michel bézian venez là hélas hélas
la meuf la anastasia est ce que j'ai
fait des millions de kilomètres pour
voir ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et absolument alors vu le comment vous
avez trouvé sa prestation pourrait dire
ces gars là alors je dois reconnaître
que c'est très convaincant oui ça
ressemblait plutôt à ça bien avant
je dirais que c'est tout à fait
remarquable vous apprendrez beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième à la troisième était la
musique direct c'est parti au débat
non
ep
[Musique]
c
et
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas ça c'est ça ça c'est
anastasia ça joue ça pourquoi beaucoup
par hp dessin depuis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas parce que je savais toi de
ce qui s'est passé
on dirait on dirait brad pitt dans
légendes d'automne ne trouvez pas moi
j'aime beaucoup le le bijou qui attire
l'attention vraiment au beau milieu des
parties le plus important mon avis oui
c'est vrai ça il a toujours les bonnes
choses allaient si matthew là attention
et voici la troisième
ce qui est insupportable c'est que jean
michel croit qu'il est bonne horrible
oui en fait elle a vraiment l'impression
il est en train de ressentir ce que
c'est que d'être - oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est bon d'être vous ça va pas
attention voici la troisième à la
stagiaire c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chevallier
j
les cerises à l'eau
je le saurai jamais
souviens toi
m
c
[Musique]
au delà c'est
je pense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon parce qu'ils avaient le même
micro que les autres mais quand il
chante n'y en a presque fait de manif
[Rires]
alors à la saison incroyable répond vous
savez je pense que c'est à vous de
décider
ou plutôt c'est une année de vocations
chez avery est véritablement en faire
votre métier
alors je anastasia pour vous qui a été
la meilleure anastasia c'est un vêtement
tous les trois alors si vous n'avez pas
chanter ma chanson je pense que j'aurais
été parfaitement convaincue que vous
êtes anastasia donc je vous ai adoré
tous les trois mais si vraiment vous me
demandez de n'en choisir qu'un pas ce
qu'il va faire non parce que juste pour
que pour que vous sachiez public va
m'aider non mais juste pour que vous
sachiez sega prix va faire ça toute sa
vie en fait derrière il fera aussi la
stasi a tout le temps donc c'est
important pour la personne voilà sachiez
je pense que c'est jean michel mr la
personne j'ai comme l'impression que
celui d'agen
[Applaudissements]
g zoug
[Musique]
merci